[Música]
olá
essa menina sou eu eu precisei muito de
limite x pra aprender a tomar conta de
mim mesma
quando as pessoas saíram de perto e
peguei uma vassoura e merey no bolo
felizmente alguém conseguiu me segurar
para evitar um desastre total de
derrubar o bolo que a minha mãe a minha
vó tinham feito com tanto carinho e aqui
estou eu a mãe avó há décadas
trabalhando com famílias e ouvindo
relatos do tipo minha filha acabou de
fazer três anos e ela diz que eu sou
muito brava
realmente eu digo não a toda hora pra
nada resolve
eu grito eu brigo é o quarto de castigo
não adianta nada nada funciona eu estou
perdida ela promete que vai se comportar
e acaba fazendo tudo de novo
eu já não sei mais o que fazer para que
ela meu bebê de sua família mas também
sentem raiva mais quando gritam e se
esperam as crianças sentem que estão
inseguros e aí se desorganizou mais
ainda e aí fazer o que respirar fundo
para tomar conta da própria raiva eu
estou quase perdendo a paciência e não
quero que isso aconteça eu sei que você
rita jangada quando não consegue fazer o
que você quer
nós vamos acalmar a gente descobriu uma
coisa bem legal pra você fazer também
quando a raiva tomar conta da criança e
dos pais também não é hora de dar
sermões e nem de falar coisas das quais
a gente se arrepende depois
nesses momentos a nossa capacidade de
raciocinar e bloquear e raciocinar e
refletir fica bloqueada
passada a tempestade da raiva
podemos rever o que aconteceu hoje de
manhã nós ficamos muito zangados uma com
a outra não foi
vamos pensar do que a gente poderia ter
feito para resolver essa história melhor
junto com a criança
podemos reescrever a história abrindo
espaço para refletir e construir novos
recursos de ação o que nos diz a
neurociência ea ciência mostra que a
arquitetura cerebral é fortemente
influenciada pela qualidade dos vínculos
afetivos com pessoas significativos
esses vínculos formam uma base sólida ou
frágil que vai repercutir o
desenvolvimento futuro refletindo em
termos de aprendizagem comportamento e
saúde nos primeiros anos de vida a
criança vive na lei do desejo é passo
que eu quero do jeito que eu quero na
hora que eu quero
o desejo surge com muita força é difícil
esperar porém alguns desses desejos
serão frustrados e outros terão a sua
realização a de nada e isso é inevitável
no entanto muitos educadores me dizem
que o fim de alguns pais o seguinte não
quero que meu filho se frustre é
possível é melhor contribuir para que a
criança aprenda a lidar com as
frustrações
quando cai ao dar os primeiros passos ou
quando um amigo lhe arranca o brinquedo
nas mãos
assim mais tarde se saberá melhor como
ele
quando leva um fora do primeiro amor
quando estudar para o vestibular e não
consegue se classificar a equipe de
trabalho encolhe e a pessoa está entre
os demitidos mas quantos sentem que não
vale a pena continuar vivendo por conta
desses desafios da vida querer poupar o
filho de todo e qualquer tipo de
sofrimento talvez de cor da falsa noção
de que felicidade é sinônimo de ausência
de problemas no entanto os estudos sobre
o tema mostram que felicidade se refere
à capacidade de consolidar a serenidade
interna
mesmo em épocas de turbulência encarar
as sustações ajuda a uma série de coisas
ajuda por exemplo a perseverar ea
fortalecer a resiliência e além disso
ajuda a capacidade de criar alternativas
viáveis
uma criança de cinco anos que está
andando bem nesse processo ela consegue
concentrar a sua atenção para montar uma
quebra cabeça sem dar ataques de raiva
quando não consegue juntar todas as
peças rapidamente outra criança da mesma
idade
porém não tão adiantada no seu
autocontrole
ela desiste ao primeiro sinal de
dificuldade espalha as peças pelo chão
com raiva interrompe a brincadeira aos
prantos incapaz de tolerar a frustração
mas há um tipo de quebra cabeça que a
criança aprende a montar ainda nos
primeiros anos de vida ela desenvolve
estratégias variados
isso para garantir a vitória insistir
acabou com a resistência da mãe chorar
amolece o coração da avó mas nem sempre
isso dá certa com o pai
não adianta chorar e fazer chantagens é
se conformar com não e buscar outra
coisa pra fazer então para acertar é
preciso errar e lidar com a frustração
de não saber
isso também vale para os adultos
especialmente os que são muito críticos
superexigentes lidar com a frustração
vai fortalecer a persistência de não
desistir facilmente diante dos
obstáculos e isso também contribui para
valorizar o erro como fonte de
aprendizagem e não como um ataque à
autoconfiança
vocês viram esse filme a família do
futuro sim quem não viu recomendo esse
personagem e luiz é o menino e inventor
e por isso mesmo muitas das suas
tentativas não dão certo
ao constatar que mais um de seus
aparelhos falhou ele consternado pede
desculpas e se surpreende ao ouvir a
reação da família você fracassou
sensacional maravilha é fracassando que
a gente aprende com sucesso a gente não
aprende nada
não desista siga em frente
porém quase sempre a criancinha sente
raiva quando se frustrou é contrariada
grita chora bate das festas de fúria
quando meu filho de 4 anos e pede alguma
coisa impossível dentro do carro é o
inferno
ele grita separar chuta banco da frente
morde o irmão não dá pra ter não dá para
dirigir no meio dessa tempestade de
raiva
de onde vem essa tempestade
o freio interna precisa ser construído
por isso é preciso um freio externo dos
limites colocados com firmeza amorosa
serenidade consistência para que o freio
interno pouco a pouco seja construído
como o controle da impulsividade ainda é
precário é mais difícil se desligar de
uma atividade interessante do que
construir uma nova
por isso é importante dizer o que pode
ser feito
em vez de repetir o que não deve ser
feito
briga como assim a no chão do quarto em
vez de já disse mil vezes publicar como
assim em cima do tapete
podemos ainda estimular a criança a
criar uma alternativa viável
isso aí que você pode quer mexer não
pode nem se eu acho que se pode
descobrir coisas que você vai poder
pegar isso facilita para que a criança
vá se encaminhando para as situações
possíveis quando o desejo não é muito
intenso
basta oferecer o objeto brinquedo para
crianças redirecionar seu interesse
então com isso a gente evita dizer não
com freqüência abrindo espaço para
crianças explorar o ambiente com o que é
possível evitar abusar do não
contribuímos para sua eficácia quando a
criança se recusa a buscar alternativas
crianças que fazem tudo o que querem
acabam se sentindo diz protegidas e
abandonados na criança pequena
o acelerador do desejo é mais forte do
que o freio da proibição
quando ela escuta não pode mexer aí vai
logo pega um objeto proibido não é
na etapa seguinte
a própria criancinha disse não não tá
logo em seguida pegou o objeto quando vê
outra criança querendo fazer o mesmo ela
repete
não não como se a proibição vale para os
outros mas não pra ela
quando freei interno está um pouco mais
desenvolvido
ela olha para o adulto tenta pegar o
objeto quando foi que não pode resistir
à tentação e vai buscar outra coisa
interessante
o autocontrole é um processo gradual
mais difícil e demorado em algumas
crianças do que em outras e mais adultos
que não conseguiram completar esse
processo e são destemperados exclusivos
impulsivos e ataca os outros quando
contrariados conhecemos muita gente
assim não é a importante a criança gosta
de perceber que os adultos reconhecem
seus desejos
antes de colocar os limites devidos eu
sei que você quer continuar brincando na
areia mas agora tá na hora de voltar
para casa
schmidt colocam cercas no terreno
transmitem amor e responsabilidade para
cuidar da criança quando se sente
compreendida a criança aceita melhor
alternativa em casa tem muita coisa boa
pra fazer vamos lhes isso facilita a
transição entre deixar uma atividade com
a qual está muito envolvida para aceitar
o limite que diz o tempo acabou
a lei do desejo vai pouco a pouco e
migrando para lei da realidade nem
sempre sabe tudo que quer nem sempre
posso fazer o que quero de jeito que eu
quero na hora que eu quero é preciso
aprender a esperar fazer combinados e
respeitá los no convívio escolar
o desejo de muitas crianças pequenas se
chocam com freqüência nem sempre dá
tempo de evitar mordidas arranhões com
papéis
os educadores conversam com as crianças
dizem que entendem que elas estão com
raiva mais mas estimula pedir desculpa
para os amigos ajudar a cuidar do
machucado que provocaram na ea fazer
combinados depois que os limites são
colocados são ações do cotidiano que vão
mostrando às crianças que a raiva tem
várias formas de ser expressa algumas
inaceitáveis e outras aceitá los e os
adultos
quantas mães fotografo o filho mordido
na creche e compartilhar nas redes
sociais
incitando a revolta do grupo quanto
equipe escolar e quando as crianças
presenciam os adultos sendo violentos no
trânsito no estádio de futebol
alimentando rede de ódio ou sendo
grosseiro que as pessoas no próprio na
própria casa
a boa notícia é que nunca tarde para a
gente aprender que é preciso tomar conta
da raiva para que ela não tome conta de
nós os adultos também precisam de
limites
eu conheço criança que tenta educar os
pais não precisa gritar já entendi
porque se diz que eu não posso bater no
meu irmão se você bate em mim
na década de 60
houve uma transição do modelo
autoritário repressor para o estilo
sentindo é dos pais não é para o modelo
permissivo é que se ignora a hierarquia
da família pais e filhos não têm os
mesmos direitos porque o nível de
responsabilidade diferente
os pais assumem uma carga maior de
compromissos de cuidar proteger e
orientar os filhos mais nem sempre isso
acontece
e às vezes nos cedo cadores sozinhos têm
que completar essa função
não dá porque a parceria família escola
é essencial para desenvolver o
autocontrole do desejo da raiva eo
respeito pelos outros
então isso tudo vai formando a base das
competências sócio-emocionais
imprescindíveis para a gente fazer
relacionamento de boa qualidade a partir
dos limites podemos desenvolver nossas
possibilidades
[Aplausos]
[Música]